mmm it is very severe the cost of
producing a liter of milk on average
throughout the year has about 28 to 30
pens and the farm gate price today is 22
23 on average but a lot of farmers are
getting less than that I've heard
figures as low as letting p a liter and
hey long can these farmers put up with
that they got the bank managers on their
back to reduce their overdraft and they
just can't do it so what is the solution
to this we know that some retailers for
example link the price they page the
cost of production would that work
better for farmers well that always
winds me up when people say retailers
are paying the cost of production so
they are on a small proportion of the
milk they buy but most of the milk they
buy is on the current liquid market
where it's 21 22 pence a litre and all
the milk product s all the milk products
cheese butter yogurt everything else is
produced from the low-priced milk
something is its it sorry so it
interrupted but I'm asking is the answer
that those particular producers should
be asked to link the price they pay to
the cost of production not the global
price yes exactly yes all the retailer's
could up the price of milk with a
affecting the price to the consumer
because there's plenty of margin in the
chain but it's not getting back to the
farm gate of course this has a knock-on
effect because I'm a grain farmer and
the the heap of wheat behind me which
was harvested yesterday it's cost us a
hundred and thirty pounds of tongue to
produce that and the current price this
morning was 105 and I've heard as low as
102 later in the day so it's not just
milk it's everything everything that's
produced at the farm land price cost of
production is for paying two kilo the
current price for lions three pain 20
unfortunately it is the case isn't it
commodity prices do fluctuate a lot
they're very volatile and peaking to the
likes of dairy UK they say this is
temporary we will get past the crisis
well here I'd like to know when this is
going back to the consumer what does the
consumer want do they want fresh liquid
milk produced on British dairy farms to
the highest welfare standard in the
world or do they want to buy imported
milk which is filled with products to
increase the shelf life and all sorts of
other nasties that we don't know of a
same with lamb lamb is coming in from
New Zealand which is depressing their
price because the supermarket's can buy
it cheaper but do the public want to
boil and that's traveled halfway across
the world as opposed the British lion
fresh from the fields produced the high
welfare standards we have heard some
retailer saying in recent weeks that
they're going to increase their
commitment to British lamb so let's hope
that continues Bruce wants good to talk
to you thank you